hey guys Ryan right here I just got back
from a screening of guardians of the
galaxy it's pretty late at night but I
have to talk about it okay excuse me if
I look tired
if I eyes are red it's not because I'm
high although this movie would have been
really cool to watch hi I mean with the
laughs and the sci-fi world yeah
guardians of the galaxy you guessed it
I'm recommending yet again another
summer movie this film was fantastic it
is the definition of pure escapism
entertainment it's just pure fun I mean
that's like what maybe the Avenger is so
great it had a lot of heart a lot of
humor that there was great visuals
there's great action great character and
I'm more than proud to say
guardians of the galaxy delivers all of
that as well
my ears say if Avengers or guardians of
the galaxy is better that's for you to
decide don't want to get into that
argument pointless argument if you want
to argue me about it I will bite your
dick off if you're a woman what I love
sex with you
consensual sex if you want to let's get
some obvious stuff out of the way the
visuals and designs are all fantastic it
felt like you're stepping into a whole
new universe it was just incredibly
detailed a lot of time not she reminded
me of like Star Trek and Star Wars but
it still has its own style I mean the
action too was pretty [ __ ] awesome
like the martial arts fight scenes that
could have thought what could have been
a little bit more creative every other
type of fighting was really [ __ ] cool
there were plenty of moments where the
audience was like damn oh [ __ ] but the
soul of this film the soul really lies
in the personality of these characters
Chris Pratt as Peter quill aka star-lord
I love Chris Pratt prior to watching
this film and even though he hadn't done
a movie that could really showcase that
he could be like an action lead I had
faith that he'd deliver and faith is a
powerful thing because guess what he did
deliver that's right Jesus was on his
side or whatever you believe and yes I
mean if it's Chris Pratt you're gonna
kind of want him to be funny and he is
really funny in this film and the
trailers that kind of made Peter quill
look kind of like an
but he's really not portrayed that way
at all in this film he's there again
he's caught he but he's lost like Chris
Pratt doesn't play up the pain but you
can you can tell there's that sense of
loneliness in him it's in the eyes he's
kind of those those eyes that just
really communicate with you you know
they connect Zoe Saldana as Gamora
gammer I forgot how to say it I mean
she's good she's likable but honestly I
kind of don't see why everyone loves her
so much
like I think Zoe Saldana is always good
I just don't think she's like anything
special this isn't to discredit her
performance but out of this main
ensemble out of the Guardians she was
the weakest performer in my opinion but
her weak is still pretty good compared
to a lot of other actresses I mean she
does a fine job but I just wasn't as
hooked into this character as I felt
like the filmmakers wanted me to be then
you got Dave Baptista's Drax the
destroyer I normally don't give two
shits about characters like this I would
not give my [ __ ] away to a character
like this the most you say normally
about a character like this is he's
badass but he's more than just badass
the wrestler turned actor and no not
Dwayne the rock Johnson not John Sara
but dave bautista really brought in
actual performance brought death it's
love house character takes like every
sentence literally he has no concept of
metaphors or expressions like you could
totally [ __ ] with this guy you're like
if you were to ask me what my name is I
could be like Jack last name off used to
be like how do you spell your name I
would go H Arry Harry middle name
initials P and my last name is ness
remember that one now here we get into
the real goods
Vin Diesel as Groot I wrote some I tried
doing a grooved impression I go in a
vein or groped [ __ ] this impression
stupid I [ __ ] love Groot he intrigued
me from the trailers alone but from the
trailers I was like what is this guy's
powers and is even really have a
personality like well they get Vin
Diesel to play with Scott any time he
speaks he says the same three words I am
Groot yes there's like tons of
personality in this character he has
like the spirit of a little boy
not that like
I know a lot about little boys I was
once a little boy so I can say that but
I don't I don't associate with little
boys just all of Gertz characters in the
expression of body language and you know
eyes expression
Vin Diesel totally brought that here and
his powers are cool he's like he's a
walking talking like tree man it's
[ __ ] awesome he has the ability to
grow there's some cool ass [ __ ] that he
can do now my favorite character in this
film and I think based off audience
reactions when I was watching it I think
they would agree with me Bradley Cooper
as Rocket Raccoon my god were to even
begin with this performance first off
he's [ __ ] hilarious
he's hilarious just remembering some of
the things he said I mean this whole
movie is funny I would say one of its
main genres is actually comedy and
Rocket he's hilarious he's blunt he
really doesn't give two shits about
people or what people think about him
but there's enough moments not just
enough where you see why rocket is the
way he is but it doesn't overplay it it
doesn't oversell it but you get just
enough so you still find him really
funny and he's also like one of the
smartest in the group he said character
all surprised you the most throughout
this film and yes badass [ __ ]
if this raccoon was real he would get
laid all the time not just with raccoons
he'd [ __ ] humans do and they'd be down I
guess if I had to give some complaints
I'd say they didn't really feel
threatened by the villain like on paper
everything sounds really good like it
sounds like obz to be threatening but in
terms of execution I didn't quite feel
that I don't think it's anyone's fault
really I think it's just because the
movie was so much fun throughout that
you I instantly believe the heroes would
concur that you don't really feel the
sense of danger but I feel like the film
was sort of aware of that like they
weren't trying to [ __ ] you or trying
to pull something over your eyes like no
it was very self-aware and there was
also some moments where the music would
change and then it would get all serious
and then a character would start getting
into some like monologue or some
expositional [ __ ] that would last like
30 seconds tops whenever that happened
which was a few times and then it would
go right back to the fun the pun just
doesn't stop with this like the
exposition will stop kind of felt like
tongue-in-cheek humor like it seemed
like they were aware
they're that these serious scenes are
kind of cheesy
we need directed by James Gunn Bravo
Bravo way to go James gun way to go what
are you gonna proud of you right
everyone give it up weren't any guests
clapping what the [ __ ] wrong with you
guys there's no one here and I even
loved the film's use of old school music
it added a different kind of flair to a
marble film does she remember the title
of guardians of the galaxy appears
you'll see you'll see what I'm talking
about let me get straight to the point
here all I gotta say guardians of the
galaxy got a galactic goal super duper
[ __ ] right all right guys thanks
for checking out my review for guardians
of the galaxy why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me which science-fiction creature would
you have sex with and I want to throw
out there to be doing a spoiler review
with Jerry so check that shisn't it out
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of my reviews
or videos is out going to click on this
but about my dick to subscribe that's
right the dick let me tell you something
about this little guardian
he has [ __ ] all kinds of vaginas
throughout the galaxy I'm talking blacks
Porto Ricans Chinese and Klingons